somewhere in this course maybe in this
plant or that herb there might be a cure
for diabetes or malaria or even your
weekly migraine and as this plant
disappears that cure disappears along
with it the rainforests of Paraguay have
long been the source of many medicinal
cures traditional folk healers often
lead the way to the plants that provide
them it's a quest to find one of
Paraguay's famed here's a shaman whose
knowledge of medicinal plants equals
that of a medical library Paraguay has
one of the highest afforestation rates
in the world and there's a hope to
record the shamans knowledge before the
forest disappears the journey begins in
paraguay's isolated badhak au Forest
Nature Reserve and the adjacent
indigenous community Toccoa ryofu where
shaman carve ACO lives the search
through the forest crosses much of the
approximately 150,000 acre reserve at
the village part of a co is consumed in
his chants and prayers perhaps to
establish a spiritual connection with
the forest
when he feels ready Herve CEO and his
medicine woman wife lead the group on
the search Herve CEO is looking for an
elusive route sometimes called suru V
also known as JA drove a Isabelly
and used for various ailments scientists
are very interested in this family of
plants for cancer research
herve co brings the route back to the
village where his wife prepares it into
a tea scientists published a book with
help from harvest forest knowledge the
book helps plants in the area to be
easily identified and studied sOooo
recording and analyzing Paraguayan
plants for possible medical cures is
urgent business trees and medicinal
plants that were once thriving are
disappearing and with them the
possibility to search for new medical
cures